oh okay oh yeah I had technical
difficulties but they've all been solved
now ah enough lollygagging enough silly
bitchery let's get to the game hold the
blue trigger to turn your flashlight on
oh okay
do I want to oh god I thought there was
gonna be some behind me oh boy
oh okay hi how you doing oh that's
lovely
oh that's the light pole what else is
gonna pop up in front of me okay hello
everybody my name is markiplier you
still over there you better be you know
hi everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome to the sisters demo now this is
a indie horror game that's coming out on
the vibe I don't know when but it's just
a demo and um there aren't a lot of
horror games out for the vibe right now
so it's kind of slim pickings but this
one seemed to be pretty decent even
though there wasn't a lot of information
on it because not fully released there's
no reviews hello oh oh hi oh oh this is
lovely very Victorian
yeah very spoopy oh hi oh hi how are you
doing
oh are you looking at me better not be
following me I'll see you in a phone oh
hi so dope Hey oh wait a minute oh you
silly little girl
you're lucky you're on the other side of
a wall here or else I'd be coming after
you are you right where the camera is
holy [ __ ] you're pretty close to where
the camera is hi
so you when I oh no what just happened
there
I had a sensor problem there maybe very
disoriented okay wait I not have my
other thing there it is I don't want to
step on it okay bye lady Jesus Christ
hello can I help you can I help you sir
okay that's No thank you I've had enough
I'm okay I got enough Girl Scout cookies
on all right okay so um also this game
was a little bit restrictive because you
required to have a room size scale so I
needed to make sure that my room was
wide enough don't do that
oh don't do that [ __ ] you what did I do
I panicked pause hello hi hey on a
second
what the [ __ ] what's under the tarp
what's under you
Oh where'd she go where the little girl
go
hi electronics doing don't problem oh my
god what is that something is going on
there wait I'm not right
hello oh jeez she got bigger she wasn't
like that before was she hi
yeah I can't figure it was gonna pop out
of me it's looking a little different is
it legs good I don't like that I don't
like that it's like following me I don't
know whatever okay hello hi what's up hi
do don't do it oh don't you do it you
little girl
you lonely little girl and you're lovely
I don't want to give you a hug that's
just what you what is happening why is
that oh [ __ ] oh hi
oh you've gotten bigger oh look how big
you've grown
oh oh you sweet little bloody eye girl
oh how much I love you shut the [ __ ] up
oh hi oh okay
[ __ ] y'all [ __ ] you what is what that's
it
I just had my life nicked with me for
like two minutes are you gonna pull that
[ __ ] on me
just gonna end it man I didn't even read
what was on the book huh where are you
guys
oh [ __ ] god damn it I didn't even get to
brag about my awesome shut up
I'm gonna go back in because I don't
think I sarva good god what the [ __ ]
happened oh come back into it this time
I'm gonna actually look I'm gonna
actually get a chance to take it in the
environment instead of being distracted
the whole time so now we're gonna pay
very close attention to what's going on
around me
hi I'm gonna be right with you I've got
to look around because there's a lot of
stuff going on here so oh okay so that's
the beginning it wasn't even looking at
me okay that's nice what's back there
there's something back there okay
there's something over here there's a
lot of stuff hang on I'll be right with
you you crazy little girl some weird
thing covered in a drape and a book can
i I'm gonna beat the [ __ ] out of you you
get over here
oh you're lucky Wow wait how close am I
to something oh you - boy you - boy you
too boy good boy
okay want you to Bowl you too boy okay
so everything's fine so far stop looking
at me ah [ __ ] any god damn man huh [ __ ]
off with that that [ __ ] where'd you go
little girl
where'd you go hi okay go open the book
okay all right
she will never let me be happy what was
that she was there in the library
[ __ ] stop do you know I'd be the one
to find her there I always found her she
was not happy shot that was his favorite
he should have loved us the same this
way we'll never be apart again she will
always be there looking over my shoulder
and he will love a smoke hi
Oh give your daddy a big hug bye how you
doing mmm you want a little smooch huh
oh you're such a pretty little princess
let me bat your head in with a
flashlight
ah [ __ ] she's after me
ah oh hey okay
that's coming [ __ ] you where you at put
your on I'm waiting
okay hello that's lucky oh [ __ ] off [ __ ]
out here just throw you out of here okay
alright can we finally read what we were
supposed to Blake so anyway that was
very short but those still very good I
like that
why isn't so sure why are the good ones
always so short oh man it's good though
it's really good anyway thank you
everybody so much for watching I'm sorry
this is so short but I can't wait for
the full version of this come out
because I kind of love the whole idea of
like a room exploration style game and I
think I I remember I found a game on
vibe that actually was like a room
escape type of deal so I might play that
in the future but thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
thought of this down in the comments
below and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
Oh what the [ __ ] okay [ __ ] off
how about a little bat I'm gonna be your
diagnose Oh like a butterfly just like a
bee